c'est l'une des plus anciennes
librairies du département mais son
histoire pourrait bientôt s'achever la
librairie Antoine installée depuis plus
de 130 ans au 16 rue Général Leclerc à
Versailles et menaçait de fermeture la
raison le propriétaire des murs a décidé
de tripler le loyer une somme que la
librairie ne peut pas payer nous sommes
dans une période de renouvellement de
bail qui a dépassé ce qu'on appelle la
période de plafonnement et donc mon
propriétaire est en droit de demander un
déplafonnement du bail il ne veut pas me
recevoir je veux lui montrer ma limite
maximum mon modèle économique pour payer
un loyer et en aucun cas le contrer le
l'embêter j'ai une échéance c'est à dire
que je peux pas engager la librairie
dans une aventure d'un loyer triplé donc
je dois me décider éventuellement de
partir et pour cela l'échéance est au 30
juin pour sauver cette institution
versaillesse ouverte depuis 1893 les
habitants du quartier la municipalité
des aut des élus locaux et même
l'animatrice Laurence Boccolini ont
apporté leur soutien à l'une des
dernières librairies du secteur c'est la
dernière librairie de Saint-Louis donc
je pense que enfin c'est très important
pour les gens du quartier d'avoir encore
cette librairie ici deux ont fermé déjà
pour moi c'est très difficile à vivre en
fait on s'est beaucoup investi avec
Antoine on a créé beaucoup de soirées
littéraires on a fait beaucoup beaucoup
de choses pour cette librairie une
pétition en ligne avait déjà recueilli
plus de 1000 signatures mais Antoine
Michon le libraire à l'origine de cette
pétition a préféré la fermer il souhaite
désormais discuter avec le bailleur pour
trouver un compromis elle perdure avec
un système astucieux peut-être de loyer
progressif peut-être de loyer un peu
indisé sur son développement peut-être
moi je suis ouvert mais il faut que je
reçoive et que l'on se voit avec ce
propriétaire nous ne sommes pas ennemis
nous sommes partenaires il y a un
propriétaire un locataire à ce jour
aucune solution n'a été trouvée
contactée le propriétaire n'a pas
répondu à nos sollicitations